So now I hope you understand how to use dictionaries. And
so the next step, we're going to go back to the search engine
code from the previous unit, and modify it to use dictionaries instead
of indexes. And this will have the big advantage that now
we can do our lookups in constant time as long as we
increase the number of buckets with the number of keywords. So to
start thinking about this, the question is which of the procedures that
we've defined for our search engine will we need to change to
make use of the dictionary instead of using the list?
So, here's the choices, all the procedures that we've defined
so far. So we had a procedure get_all_links, and get_all_links
would scan a web page, return a list of all the
links in that web page. We had the procedure crawl_web;
we have crawl_web, which started with a seed page, and
then followed all the links that could be found in
that page collecting pages, and for each page, collecting the keywords
on that page and adding them to the search
index. We have add_page_to_index that would take a page; it
was called by crawl_web when it, a new page was
found and would add that page to the index by
finding all the words on that page, adding them to
the index. We had add_to_index, which would take the index,
a keyword and the URL where it was found and
add that location to the index. And we had lookup,
which would take a keyword and give us a list of all the URLs
where that keyword would appear. So to answer this, you may need to look at
the code, and you'll find it on the website. Think about which ones of
these procedures we'll need to change to
replace the list index with the dictionary index.